El pequeño Mohamed ya se ha recuperado
el cólera se infectó hace unas semanas
cuando la enfermedad se extendió en los
campamentos dar sal ahora su madre alias
Toma las medidas necesarias para
prevenir que el resto de la familia se
contagie
enfermo no pensé que pudiera ser cólera
no había oído hablar de esa enfermedad
desde que era una niña estamos alerta
por si hay más casos Así que no dejo que
mis hijos estén en contacto con otras
tiendas el cólera reaparecido después de
30 años con más de 4.800 casos la
mayoría en el norte del Líbano la
localidad de arsal donde se concentra el
mayor número de refugiados es una zona
de alto riesgo para hacer frente al
brote de cólera las ong sobre el terreno
ayudan con las tareas de desinfección y
supervisión de los suministros de agua
en las áreas afectadas
tener acceso suficiente a cantidad y
calidad de agua segura es una de las
medidas preventivas más importantes para
que no se extienda el brote de cólera La
amenaza al cólera se ha disparado en el
Líbano responsables de la salud estiman
que el número de afectados podría
superar los 300.000 debido a la
virulencia de la cepa actual con una
tasa de letalidad del 2%. los casos de
cólera también han aparecido en los
núcleos urbanos como este vecindario
concienciar a los vecinos en la
prevención de la enfermedad es otra de
las medidas que más puede ayudar al
tener la epidemia Así que
la situación crítica a los hospitales
libaneses por el deterioro de la
economía presenta nuevos desafíos para
lucha contra el cólera
hemos puesto a disposición todos
nuestros recursos con este hospital de
emergencia y la campaña de vacunación
pero el problema es que muchas familias
no tienen acceso a agua limpia ni
desinfectantes si no frenamos el cólera
la capacidad hospitalaria se verá
desbordada
la epidemia se está extendiendo
rápidamente y amenaza con hundiera al
Líbano en más incertidumbre
desesperación y crisis si no se medidas
urgentes para garantizar el acceso a
agua y saneamiento los brotes de cólera
volverán con regularidad en el futuro